this is a production of Cornell
University okay so today I'll be talking
about uh genomics and high througho
phenotyping of Cava bronck viruses they
told me if I need to point I need to
move so I'll keep moving right so today
we're talking about casava so the
outline today will be talking about Caba
Bron stri disease phenotyping which I'll
refer to as cbsd in the presentation and
we'll also be talking about Tru necrosis
image analysis uh cbsd virti
quantification and also just a summary
from the findings of This research so
Cava is a is an outbreeding species it's
a bushy shrub that's grown for its roots
mainly so but in eastern central Africa
they grow it for also the leaves because
they use the leaves to make like stews
and pests so it feeds over 800 million
people in the the world and as of 2022
the value of casava was $4.9 billion in
treade around the world it's propagated
by Stam cuttings that's what farmers do
mainly but breeders we could generate
seeds which are always very difficult to
generate so despite the importance of
Cava in easn central Africa there's Cava
BR strike disease so this is a viral
disease that's very unique in how it
expresses its symptoms that you know you
could see a healthy plant but when you
uproot The Roots that's like after 12 to
15 months after planting you will see
the okay you will see these patchy
necrotic lesions so this is always very
difficult to eat such Cava because it's
the necrosis is hard and you can't boil
the cassa and you can't also feed it to
animals so Caba Bron chake disease is a
positive s single stranded RNA virus
it's in the genus iomo virus and the
family poort virid you know potato virus
Y which is a very common virus so these
are common plant viruses but there are
two species of this virus the Uganda
Cava Brown streke virus and which I'll
refer to as cbsv in the
presentation the casava Bron streak
virus and the Uganda Cava Bron strike
virus both viruses cause 70 to 100%
healed losses in suceptible varieties so
when we think about the genomics of Cava
Bron stre virus just like any other
poort virus it's recorded as one big
polyprotein that tends to be cut into
different pieces depending on the need
you know how the plant interacts with
how the virus interacts with the plant
so the big difference with cbsd which is
down this is the Genome of cbsd the
biggest difference between cbsd and
other viruses in the eomo virus genus is
this H one protein so this is a protein
that is not encoded by all the other
viruses in the eomo virus genus and we
think that it's because of this uh frin
that it's possible for casaba Brown stri
viruses to be transmitted by white flies
and not AIDS so most of the virus in
this genome for Vector biology they
encod the HC pro protein that helps with
Aid transmission so that's the only
difference but most times the proteins
are the same so when we look at the
distribution of casaba bran chake
disease this is a very old map from far
but I could tell you what's happening so
C Brown St disease in the 1930s was
discovered in the coastal regions of
East Africa so the virus would only
survive at uh altitude at very low
altitudes that's below 1,000 MERS below
sea level above sea level so but as of
2000 the virus moved up to higher
altitudes that has never been reported
and that's why we have the Uganda Cava
Bron virus because that's where where it
was discovered in Uganda while Cava
brownst virus was the original virus
that was at the coast of East Africa so
as of last year we have confirmed cases
in the Democratic Republic of Congo
Zambia and the Central African Republic
so you would wonder why breeders in East
Africa are very interested in West
Africa so if you look at the Food
Systems across Africa West Africa is
highly dependent on casava In Their Food
Systems they don't have Alternatives
right so the alternative could be yum
but everything is largely casava so you
imagine if casava Brown strike virus
moves from East Africa to Central to
Western Africa then we're going to for
we are going to face a lot of food
scarcity on the continent so that's why
we're trying to make sure that we breed
for it within East Africa and not get it
moved to West Africa so this virus as I
have mentioned is transmitted by white
flies there are many white fly
populations across Africa but also the
greatest transmitters of the disease are
farmers because they tend to carry
infected planting material from one
place to another so that's how the virus
has moved and also evolved to different
isolates and different species so to
find Cava Bron stri disease in the field
it's its sympt its folar symptoms are
not very threatening so you see fosis
along the secondary Leaf margins it's
never on the main Leaf margin it's the
secondary margins it's easy to confuse
it for you know just normal chosis cenis
but with a a trained eye someone could
see the LIF patterns and know that this
is cbsd so you also see brown strikes on
the stem if you take a good look but
also these also tend to happen on the
Botanical seeds so that's a sign of cbsd
so when you appro the root this is
always about 12 to 15 months after
planting you see the contriction in The
Roots but also when you cut there the
dark Necro patches in the road so those
are those are symptoms of Cava Bron stri
disease and they cause up to 100 million
dollar in economic losses in East Africa
so when we are scoring Cava brownst
disease we have this one to five scoring
method that was originally developed for
Caba Mosaic disease but also works
efficiently for Caba Bron stri disease
so a score of one means no observable
symptoms while a score of five is the
highest severity that you can observe
either both on the leaves or on the road
so we tend to score these at 3 months
and 6 months after planting for the fure
because that time the root has not
developed once you approach Cava you can
not you know you destroy the plants so
we have to wait 12 months to look at the
root so for nearly 10 decades because I
mentioned Cava Bron stri disease has
been around since the 1930s so if we
count we've done a lot of breeding for
casava Bron disease but we've not
identified markers that have been vly
debed in any population so to my work we
wanted to understand the genetic
architecture of casava Bron stri disease
conduct genome wide Association studies
for Cava Bron stri disease and explain
these results from a breeding
perspective so we studying a pathogen
but we are also breeders so we need to
explain it from a breeding context so as
John Luke mentioned the last 10 years
the next gen Cava has Cava project has
been founding Cava research in Africa
and genomic sele ction was one uh tool
that you know to that they promoted for
you know rapid selection and
accelerating of breeding so we have this
genomic selection population that was
developed in the first years of the next
gen project and you know we have it it's
a s population it had
471 clones that were evaluated in the
clonal evaluation trials so when you
think about casava breeding we have a
Seedling trial we have a clono
evaluation trial Advanced field trial
then the farmer trial so a clone
evaluation trial is as much diverse as
you know the seedling trial but we have
replication in this case that we don't
get ining trials so we planted these
trials in two locations that have
varying cbsd pressure there cbsd but the
pressure varies then out of these 471
clones only 3002 clone 20 clones were
genotyped we planted this in an
augmented block design with three checks
and we use spread AR row within the
field to aument the disease pressure so
once we had the population we had we had
different hypothesis that we wanted to
test out how you know the population
performed best on the one toi scoring
method then we took root necrosis images
because we were curious is this necrosis
due to environmental factors or is it
genetic and also we did viral titer
quantification or viral Lo
quantification and that's how we
phenotyped the C2 population so moving
ahead I will talk about definitions
because as someone who works with both
breeders and Pathologists is important
to define the context of things that
I'll be talking about so if I talk about
tolerance it means that uh this is the
ability or the capacity of a clone to be
infected but still give you know
satisfactory yield to breeders when I
talk about susceptibility this clone has
the ability to get cbsd but you know the
disease varies or the expression of
symptom varies when I mention enhancers
of susceptibility this is the likelihood
and the severity of the infection based
on the symptoms right so it's when when
it's time to think about viruses I'll
mention that this is based on the virus
but if I mention it anywhere in the
presentation it's due to the symptoms
then incidence again is how frequent
these symptoms occur in the population
so let's go to the one to five scoring
method this paper has been published so
we had the C2 population we wanted to
find out you know just understand the
population based on the one to5 squaring
method so the research objective is we
wanted to evaluate the cbsd trait
variability based on the one to five
scoring method within this population uh
establish phenotypic and genotypic
correlations then conduct Jas both
univariate and M VAR Jas to identify
genomic regions that were associated to
these traits and also provide
information on functional and atted gen
within those regions so when we talk
about J using the one to5 scoring method
forava Brown disease a few Studies have
been conducted it's important to mention
that uh kuchi kao's population and
kondo's population are grandparents of
the C2 population so they did CH studies
and they form kondo phone that cbsd at 3
months uh Snips on chromosome 11 were
associated to cbsd at 3 months after
planting while at 6 months after
planting we only had Snips on chromosome
4 and chromosome 11 no associations were
discovered with the cbsd at 12 months
after planting that's on the road so the
same thing was observed with kaoi that
he only picked out uh cbsd at 6 months
after planting Snips on chromosome 11 so
other studies within East Africa these
are mainly best in Tanzania and Kenya
have done qtl studies with uh this
population namikonga and choba just to
give you a brief introduction in the
1930s when cbsd happened breeders did
cross uh uh noral casava domesticated
casava clones with the wild relatives
and this namikonga like a clone like
namikonga Ora is is from that breing
program in the 1930s so two Studies have
been done using qtl studies and you can
again see that they pick out different
genomic regions Associated to the
different severity scores either on the
Folia or in the root symptoms so that
tells you that you know some work has
been done but it's really difficult to
pinpoint which region in the genome is
actually uh controlling cbsd severity
scor so back to my work we did want to
ask were what we were observing in the C
population due to genetics environment
or genotype by environment interactions
so we did partition the variance and you
can see that for the C2 population uh
most of the traits that we measured cbsd
incidence and severity were highly
genetic while when it comes to genotype
by environmental interaction you can see
for root uh sority scores that G by E is
zero right so what we see is due to
genetic or the environment so we also
looked at uh variation in Broad sense
and narrow sense heritability estimates
for Broad St heritability this is data
from the combined data data from the
different locations
you could see that the estimates
generally range from moderate to high
and this is the same with published
previous published papers for cbsd and
also the same trend is observed with
Naros sensor ability estimate that they
tend to be low to moderate depending on
the Trad and this is again the same as
it's been observed in other studies so
we went ahead to do Univar G analysis
and for our Univar GS analysis you could
see that we only picked out Association
for cbsd at 3 months after planting on
chromosome 1 chromosome 13 and
chromosome 18 so as I mentioned that the
ancestors of the C2 population they
picked out Snips on either chromosome 4
or chromosome 11 in our population we do
not pick out chromosome 4 or chromosome
11 so we went ahead to do multivariate
gas but it's important to note that on
chromosome 1 and chromosome 18 there's
an ingression that from the 1930
populations that were developed so so we
have ingressions on chromosome 1 and
chromosome 18 so when we did multivar
Jas we wanted to find out which regions
which Snips we identified in the univ
Jas were shared among these traits would
show up among these traits so we again
saw that some of these Snips are shared
across you know different trait
combinations and because of this we had
confidence to search for candidate genes
within this regions to see what type of
function do these genes do so we
characterized gene on ologies which may
not be very informative now but we
wanted to claster them so based on
molecular function you could see that we
have you know cataly uh genes in those
regions that control catalytic activity
binding you know cellular processes uh
cellular anatomic entities so the
conclusion from this is you know the
genes that we received in this case
would be enhancers of symptom severity
so if symptom severity because when you
look at you know the virus how the virus
proteins work viruses tend to depend on
the host for their replication so all
these help the virus reproduce within
the host and that's how we get the
diverse severity scores within the
population so to summarize this section
cbsd incidence in the C2 population
symptom incidence was at
44% so that shows that while genomic
selection you know they've been genetic
gains from a breeding from a disease
perspective the disease is still
occurring in the population and we also
had a moderate to high broad sense
heritability estimates that's good are
low to moderate narens heritability
estimates 77 functional genes potential
C genes were found the activities again
help in symptom uh severity within the
plant so I will go to my second
objective which was done with uh with in
collaboration with Chris uh who used to
work for breed in
Cornell uh so this is the genetic
architecture the genetic analysis of
Caba Bron root necrosis using image
analysis and genom Association studies
so when we think about root necrosis if
you remember the picture that I showed
you of the one to five scoring method we
score the fure symptoms twice in our
breeding cycle while root necrosis can
only be scored once so we wanted to
expand you know how we could uh
characterize a phenotype cbsd necrosis
so image analysis was the best option
that we T about so we know that brute
necrosis is the most devastating cbsd
symptoms because once you have R
necrosis you cannot eat that Cava and
then we thought that image analysis
could expand this R necrosis the
question that we had is we've observed
these variations in R necrosis patterns
but were these variations due to
genetics or due to environmental factors
that was yet to be found out so I'll
show you what led to our hypoth thesis
of studying root necrosis you can see
that you know there are different
expression patterns of rot necrosis we
agree that you know this could be due to
you know environmental factors it could
also be due to the isolates within the
field so there are so many factors that
you know lead to these necrotic pattern
so we collected uh different images and
used them for analysis to study Ro
necrosis so we use plant CV which is an
open source you know software for
segmentation of areas of interest in an
image this is the python best method you
know we have the ability to extract
Futures based on size shape color
texture and so we inputed images in uh
PL CV and then we got an output file
that we use for Downstream data analysis
so the experiment of Designing this Cas
is we collected five roots from a plant
from each plant in a plot a plot is made
up of 10 plants so each plant five roots
imag were captured at the proximal end
of the route the middle and the distal
end images were collected in both
locations across both years we use
tablets with f field book to ensure like
it was a way of controlling the data we
got that if we say this is a plot then
it's an actual plot and an actual image
of that plot then it's also important to
notice that to mention that numerous
people capture these images so Styles in
how they held you know the tablets
affected our Downstream data analysis
since we had to take out some images
since they were they didn't meet uh the
the plant CV criteria so we took out
numerous images again the research
objectives we wanted to characterize
root necrosis image traits uh determine
phenotypic and genotypic correlations
best with the one to five scoring
methods and also conduct GS and also
identify you know the genes in those
regions so how this happened in image
analysis just to give you we would input
a raow image in IM in plant CV then we
use different color spaces for Segment
for segmentation so we ended up using
the lightness the green the magenta the
blue and yellow because this was better
for us in the segmentation process then
we would extract the morphological
features of the root dis like in this
case and also in another step extract
the image the morphological features of
the necrosis itself and we had an output
file so we ended up collecting data like
the TR that we studied were the
percentage of necrosis so the area of
necrosis over the whole area of the root
dis times 100 uh the necrotic area
fraction the necrotic W fraction the
solidity of necrosis you know and
numerous other trats that we studied so
we were curious what these trats you
know what's the heritability of these
threats so looking at these trats all
the image and analysis St the BR
heritability was generally low to
moderate you can see the percentage of
necrosis had
42 uh you know uh heritability while you
know like the solidity of necrosis or
the C area of necrosis had very low
heritability the lowest heritability
estimates again we see the the trend you
know very low heritability Nar
heritability estimates associated with
these image traits so we also wanted to
find out how these threats really
perform against the one to five scoring
method because that's those are scores
that we used to and understand best as
breeders so you could see that some
traits were highly clustered together so
those are highly correlated traits while
other traits like the solidity of
necrosis and the eclipse eccentricity of
necrosis were negatively correlated with
all the other word necrosis image traits
when we compare it to the one to five
scoring method you can see that uh cbsd
at 12 months after planting is has good
correlations with you know all these rud
necrosis traits that are highly
correlated with each other while the
fure symptoms are not really that
correlated with all these other traits
so we also looked at genotype by uh
environment uh effect on our population
on our image population and you can see
that the
S the Ser 2020 and Dong uh in both years
were highly correlated right images from
populations from these locations were
highly correlated well for the S 2019
has you know a very different
correlation from this this is because in
the S 2019 we had a drought at this
experiment and lost most of the plants
that we had in that field so the images
that we colle we collected were much
less and if you plot this out you could
see that the environment was different
from all the other environments so we
went ahead to look at the variations in
phenotypic correlations and you can see
again their traits just like you saw in
the biplot for the genotype uh for the
genotype by tra interactions you could
see that there are some trats that are
highly correlated with each other and
then we have this bunch of traits that
you know have moderate to low
correlations and then when we look at
cbsd severity cause they have you know
very poor correlations with all the
image analysis traits except for a few
with cbsd at 12 months after planting
but it's still you know very little cor
correlations like the correlation
between the percentage of necrosis and
cbsd are 12 months after planting it's.
three so that's a low correlation but
still good so the same Trends were
observed with uh the genotypic
correlations that you could see that
there are bunches that you know these
are highly correlated these have low to
moderate correlations and then again we
have very poor correlations but
following the same Trend like with the
phenotypic correlations so we went ahead
to do Univar Jus and only two two Snips
we found associations with two Snips uh
with two traits the eclipse eccentricity
of necrosis with found Snips on
chromosome uh seven and 11 which didn't
show up when we did uh the univarate GS
analysis with the one to five scoring
method but has showed up in the
ancestors of the C2 population and then
again we see the percentage of necrosis
having Snips on chromosome are one so we
did multivar Jas and we did not the
different tra combinations we not find
any significant Snips with the multivar
Jus so again we looked at the gene
functions and you see again the same
Trend that follows that you see
catalytic activity you would see binding
and all these Gene functions again help
in the suscep in enhancing the
susceptability or the expression of the
symptoms within the roots so to
summarize this chapter we know that
heritability estimates were much lower
than the the ones of the one to five
scoring method because with thought you
know using images would take away biases
that the one to5 scoring method tends to
capture but that didn't happen we saw
similar Trends in genotypic and
phenotypic correlations again Snips only
Associated to two traits were identified
and the genes in those regions again
enhanc symptom expression in cbsd so
that was my objective two going to the
objective three this was done uh so we
collaborate with the dsmz which is a
virus Research Institute in Germany so
this is the genetic complexity of casaba
brri disease Insight from Q PCR best
virti quantification and genome wide
Association studies this work was done
in collaboration with Dr winter and Dr
summer who work at the dsmz so when we
talk about cbsd titer the spelling of TI
depends on whether you're trained with
British English or American English but
it's the same thing or viral Lord you
know it's just the concentration of the
virus within a a biological sample so it
depends on you know the method that you
use so since we use qpcr you know we got
CT values that we use to calculate uh
relative uh amounts of TI within a plant
because we had a reference uh a
reference that we used and used that to
detect the amount of virus in our plants
so how this was done is we collected
root diss that we compile together for a
plot like a it sample and then those
brute discs were dried and shipped to
the dsmz and then the QP shs were done
at the dsmd and we got the results back
so again our objectives for this uh
section was to assess a cbsv these are
the two virus species of the disease
that we are studying CC disease cbsv and
UC cbsc within that two uh within the C2
population we wanted to establish
phenotypic and genotypic cor relations
again do Js univ Js and provide insights
into these gyms so when we look at both
viruses in both locations you could see
when we look at the presence this is uh
plus his presence minus is absence when
we look at the presence absence of cbsd
we see that cbsv is more prevalent
across you know the locations and also
in the combined data set uh compared to
ucbsv but we know that you know as as we
trans as we planted you know from one
year to another there's an increase of
cbsd so to explain what's happening why
cbsv is more predominant than new uh
than new cbsv is because uh some Studies
have shown that ucbs cbsv really gets
much faster than ucbsv plants have a
mechanism of stopping the replication of
cbsv so it may be in the plan but it
just doesn't increase at a fast rate
like CBS ESV does we also know that uh
the increase from one year to another
could be because we replant planting
materials so you imagine if the
infection happened in the first year and
then you're replanting that you know
that clone you're still passing the
virus over to the next Generation giving
it more time to replicate and the virus
to increase so we also wanted to find
out is virus tighter due to genetics
environment or genotype by environment
interactions so you could see for CB for
UC cbsv despite not being very PR valent
in the population it's highly due to
genetics but cbsv which is more
predominant is due to uh very little of
it is due to genetics what we are
observing but when we look at genotype
by environment interaction you can see
cbsv has G high G by E while ucbsv has
low G by E this could be explained by
again this is a limitation of our study
we did not test the different isolates
and strains within our location where we
planted these CA varieties so we think
that those isolates have different
interactions with the genotypes and
that's why we saw high G by E so moving
forward we recommend that breeders you
know should periodically test for
isolates in this experimental uh in this
experimental areas to account for those
in the analysis so when we looked at
genotype when we looked at genotypic
phenotypic correlations again we see
that there are very poor correlations
with the one to five scoring methods
both phenotypic and uh and uh genotypic
correlations it's important to also
mention that cbsv and new cbsv were not
correlated so that brings it to the
notion that these are two different
viruses acting differently despite both
of them being Cava Bron viruses so we
did gas and we found some regions that
were associated to uh cbsv titer this
was done in gap
that you see chromosome 10 chromosome 13
chromosome 17 and 18 were associated uh
to cbsv TI while numerous regions in a
gome were picked out with the ucbsv tier
some of these snps that we picked really
explained you know reasonable
proportions of variance when we compare
it to the one to5 soring method so this
that was a good thing again we looked at
the proportion the genes in those
regions of interest and again we see
these are enhancers of you know disease
symptoms as has been observed with all
the other phenotypes that we were
studying so we also curious if we
included uh ucbsv and cbsv TI Viro TI as
a coar for the one to five scoring
method when we wanted to improve the
Precision but also there's the concept
of Tolerance right where if if you
account for tighter then you could pick
out regions that control tolerance so
the plant has the virus but then it
gives you good you know yield so we did
not pick anything when we used cbsv
vartia as a coar for the one to5 scoring
method and also the same Trend was for
ucbs virusa as a CO nothing interesting
came up so summarizing this uh both cbsv
and UC cbsv are present in the
population you know so while we say that
uh the incidence was at 44% this is
confirmed by the qpcr result
we know that cbsv despite being
predominant is is highly controlled by
genotype by environment interactions and
that comes to our recommendation that
you know sampling and characterizing of
isolates within location should be part
of routine breeding uh activities we
know we identify that there are no
correlations between cbsv and new cbsv
titer so that's the implication is
Breeders moving forward should treat
these as two different diseases and
develop strategies that are different
from each other
so we also noticed that again different
genomic regions are associated to the
trade that again drives to the point
that these are two different viruses
that should have two different breeding
strategies so to conclude uh this talk
we had research der variables our aim
was to characterize the C2 population uh
we wanted to expand phenotyping in
addition to the one five soring method
introduced root necrosis image analysis
and large scale virus TI quantification
which we did so but based on this
there's no clearcut method based on the
one to five scoring method that we could
recommend for breeders breeders have to
do a cost benefit analysis to choose
either to do you know virus tit
quantification or image necrosis but
again more research is needed before
they could you know make those decisions
and we expanded our knowledge on cbsd
tile quantification so moving forward as
we were talking you notice different
groups tend to identify different ecomic
regions based on the you know the
population that they use right so we are
proposing that if you know the casava
community could do a meta study for all
these uh published papers and have like
a baseline right that breeders could
follow rather than everybody have their
own thing own population we also uh
recently the Latin American lines they
are lines that were characterized for
cbsd in the greenhouse and these lines
don't you know they have differential
responses to cbsv but the most important
thing is they don't get infected by
either you know so you could find a line
that's not infected by cbsv but is
highly susceptible to use cbsv so
breeders could integrate this in their
breeding populations and you know
develop resistance since we've
recommended a different breeding
strategy for both viruses so that brings
me to an end I would like to acknowledge
you know my committee that that was John
L Michelle he and Keith
the NRI team in Uganda the John Lani
club we have the people from dsmz The
Next Gen project and the M lab yeah
thank you I'll take any
questions so for the differ the Snips
that we used were about 37,000 Snips uh
that se gave us fewer Snips but there's
this imputation work that had been done
by man so we combined you know the
former GBS Snips with the dat to improve
the number to get them to 30 37,000
about that if I have it right off head
uh for most like the to5 scoring method
and the virus titer quantification we
use the bueron threshold for the gas
which is very conservative but it was
good uh the root necrosis image analysis
so we did the modified bueron correction
threshold where you calculate for you
calculate a correlation Matrix for the
number of snips on each chromosome and
then you use that in calculating the
threshold so it was a more conserve uh
it was a more flexible so it's between
it's not the FDR it's not uh as uh less
stringent like the false Discovery red
but it's also not very stringent like
the buffoni correction threshold so it's
in the
middle
yes yeah it's so I I tried out again
this is not like uh hacking a method I
tried out the FDR and I was getting
again too many sniffs that you know just
because it's a low threshold you get so
much that you could not explain or
interpret so I decided to go with the
stringent one that I'm very sure that
you know if a snip passes that threshold
then it something has to be happening in
it so again I think it's um because when
we're calculating Naros sensoril we use
the markers so if we have markers that
don't have like high density markers so
that could be a limitation to why we're
getting low Nance heritability
estimates so it's it's still a rough one
in my head but we want uh to because
through the next gen we've generated all
this data so the program at Morag we
have all this data in casava base so we
want to rerun the gws analysis as a with
all these cons that what done and
published and then uh from that we could
you know start talking about what we're
seeing any differences or any similar
any similarities that you know could be
used as a baseline for the population so
it's still uh a rough idea but I think
standardizing uh what people use for you
know determining What's significant in
relation with cbsd is
important
so the one 125 scoring method has been
used so we have data from since cbsd
breeding started so I apologize for
thinking that's the everybody knows
that's the method but across East Africa
and central Africa the one to five
scoring method is the standard method
that's using that's used so we will do
that based on the symptom severity
scores from the one to five scoring
method image analysis should be uh
should come in if a breeder feels
it would add value to their breeding
program but we're not recommending it
for all breeding programs because one
someone needs to know how to extract the
images from plant CV you know the
analysis part of it is also something
that I don't think every breeding
program has capacity on so the one to
five scoring method is understood and
will be used yeah
yes so the three we took uh images at
the top part of the root so that's one
image the middle part and the bottom
part of the root just the same format
that they use when they're scoring C
Bron stke disase so they will cut the
root I think three times and then uh
three times not I think three times then
they'll give an average score of you
know the score that the cbsd score that
they saw at the different places in the
road so that's the same method we use so
each roote had uh three images uh we had
I think 150 IM measures per plot yeah so
we did not look at that specifically but
we have the data to answer that question
if there's variability within the
different parts of the plant and does
this vary within the plot and between
plots so that's we didn't look at but we
have the data to look at it in future
yeah yes or
not
so there is a whole project on uh White
fly Behavior with C Bron St disease I've
not seen any research any ql research
from that group but if they do you know
identify those regions then it would be
possible to look at those regions and
see how they you know uh correlate or
are the same with the regions that we're
picking out so that's also a limitation
of the study we did not account for
white flies but we know that white flies
did transmit the infection for us
yeah okay so I think uh this is Richard
uh
Ricky uh so for the collection of the
categorical disease SC was the data
labored and who collected the data Ricky
the data was labeled so we used a field
book to collect this data so we know
uh we know exactly what the Clone is we
also have uh backward scanners in the
field to help us identify which plot
which plant is that then the second part
of the question is uh do you think
accounting for R effects in your models
would improve the results the answer is
yes we know that uh breeders have you
know depending on who's who's scoring
and their experience they would give a
different score to the same plant so we
not account for R biases but we know
that that bias exists and that's why we
try to use image analysis to eliminate
that bias but we did not get great
results with the image analysis so Ricky
I hope that has answered your
question